The good, the bad, and the ugly.
This is a recitation for
the visualization week.
With great power comes
great responsibility.
There are many ways to
visualize the same data.
You have just seen how to make
quite attractive visualizations
with ggplot2, which has
good default settings,
but judgment is still
required from the user.
For example, do I decide
to vary the size of a point
or do I vary the
color of a point?
It is worth noting at
this point that Excel
and other similar
programs can also
be used to make perfectly
acceptable visualizations,
or terrible ones.
The tool can help but it's
ultimately up to the user
it to make decisions.
So what is the difference
between a good visualization
and a bad visualization then?
I would argue that
a good visualization
clearly and accurately conveys
the key messages in the data.
A bad visualization will
obfuscate the data either
through ignorance or malice.
So what does this mean?
Visualizations can
be used by an analyst
for their own consumption to
gain insights into the data.
Visualizations can also be
used to provide information
to a decision maker and/or to
convince someone of something.
Now, a bad
visualization can hide
patterns that could give insight
or mislead decision makers.
This is where the
malice part comes in.
So today, we will look at a
few examples of visualizations
taken from a variety of sources.
We'll discuss what is good
and what is bad about them.
Then we will switch into R to
build better versions of them
for ourselves.
But I want you to think for
yourself in this presentation.
You might not agree with
all the points I make
or my opinions about
these visualizations.
Visualization is
inherently subjective
and the right visualization
will depend on the situation.
So use your own
judgment and think
about what I talked about
before with a good visualization
and a bad visualization.